hey what's up my name is Samuel Le and
in this video I'm going to be rating all
of the different moneymaking schemes and
skills that there are from worst to best
I'm here with my brother and business
partner Russell Leeds we have not
discussed this prior to this debate
right now I say debate we might agree it
might be everything's agreed it might be
that everything's agreed I have written
down all of the different things I can
think of stock market investing Drop
Shipping garage sailing cryptocurrency
copywriting rent to rent Forex deal
selling affiliate marketing and network
marketing I've obviously not put
property investing in there there's a
couple of property things because I
thought property investing obviously I'm
going to say 10 because this is a
property investment Channel these are
the other stuff so we'll start with the
stock market boom what are you saying
stock market 1 to 10 how good of a
money-making investment scale is it I
think the stock market is is decent what
did you ra out of 10 seven okay I've got
six okay and I think that the stock
market investing I mean obviously you
can invest in the stock market you can
also trade with the stock market Market
I'm really talking about investing in
the stock market I think it's boring but
I think that it's safe I think compared
to a lot of stuff like cryptocurrency
well it depends you say it's safe it
depends what you which stock you're
investing in right if you're investing
in individual index funds presum but
this is presuming that you're skilled in
it right you can say that about anything
you could say if you're crap at it not
really property yeah if you're crap at
property investing you lose a lot of
money you could buy a lemon could buy a
property that you think's got great
potential to be developed true we've
even done that but if you're just buying
generic vanilla I suppose that's the
same as buying an index fun isn't it
right yeah fair enough so it's it's
reasonably safe if you do it right but
it's boring it's not going to get you
quickly I don't find it super exciting I
no it's definitely not quick it's
definitely a very slow way but I think
it's a solid way a lot of people do it
in America it's much more popular in
America it is the thing I love about
property though and I'm not just going
to keep talking about how great property
is with property you can do the slow
boring vanilla stuff but you can also do
the quick exciting stuff anyway next
Drop Shipping right out of 10 six I put
six no I didn't I put five I'm slightly
more optimistic that every vote so far
I've been one up on you drop shipping to
me is great if you're a teenager or
something I mean Maybe I'm Wrong tell me
if I'm wrong and in the comments tell me
if I'm being har I'm not a big fan come
on imagine like 40 years old wife and
kids and that and you they drop shipping
if I was working in JD Sports making
£2,000 a month and I hated my job Drop
Shipping all the way cool no problem I
mean maybe I'm wrong I don't know I
don't know enough about it but the next
one's similar which is garage sailing
that I think is ridiculous I'm going to
give it a zero no it's zero it is a zero
it's the kind of thing that you could do
you shouldn't even be thinking about the
reason it's a zero is because that
should not those thoughts should not
even be in your head what is garage so
you go to car boot sales or you go to
garages get stuff for real cheap peanuts
and then put it on Facebook Marketplace
and sell it for a reasonable price and
you make money it's an entrepreneurial
skill I wouldn't give it a zero no it's
a zero because it's it's not normally
that what it normally is is what have we
got in our house that we could sell
you've turned turned it into a bit of a
business I think it is a bit of a
business G Ang talks about garage
selling doesn't I if you're just selling
your own crap it's zero listen it's a
zero if you're selling other people's
crap you make it all right you go this
what you're doing you go another thing
that Gary V talks about is he says like
you can go on like uh Faceook
Marketplace and get free stuff get free
stuff and then sell it for like cheap I
would do that if I was 177 18 if my kids
did that I'd be like yeah well done kids
yeah it's but if you did it mate it's
want to but from a paper round yeah it
is yeah it almost is did you know what
though you know what I don't want to do
on this video I don't want to poo poo
anybody cuz some people are working in
jobs in factories making, 1500 quid and
for for for them start this is a really
good starting point ah it's not why cuz
you starting you're doing the wrong
thing you're climbing the wrong tree
you're doing the wrong you shouldn't be
I don't think you should be doing that
unless you're a child that's harsh bro
I'd give it a three it's between a zero
and one why does Gary vay because he
seems like a good person right I've met
him yeah why would he tell people to do
garage salent do you know it's like the
Dave Ramsey kind of mindset for me that
is it's like this the scrimping and the
set like I think it's crap all right
next one is uh cryptocurrency I mean
we've done a little bit of
cryptocurrency we've we've dipped our
toe water Rob Kaki who I respect greatly
who is a living legend is a massive
advocate for investing in Bitcoin right
I'm not I think I don't like it much
there's no service there's no you're not
adding value to anyone or anything if
you in again sorry to keep going about
property if you invest don't have going
about property go about being garage
sales at least there a at least you're
adding value somewhere yeah you're
taking someone's junk and then you're
finding you're repackaging it yeah right
so why did you give it a zero then huh
cuz you shouldn't be doing it you're
messing around in the wrong in the wrong
Market L you're adding value to somebody
making money at least how much have you
made from cryptocurrency I have made
money on it but it's any any money that
I've made on cryptocurrency has has been
absolutely 1 billion per luck I've not
felt like yeah man I deserve that I did
well and I've lost money as well could
I've lost money as well could you not
argue that index funds are similar
though is it is it not the equivalent to
that the the thing is with index funds
there's the history of it going up and
up and up what worries me about crypto
and this is why potentially could even
be worse than Carriage sales even though
that was a zero I actually genuinely
think you could very easily lose
everything and lose a lot of money I
wouldn't even personally I wouldn't
invest anything in crypto that I wasn't
100% happy to lose for a bit of fun
experiment with businesses whereby when
you win it's at someone else's expense
which is cryptocurrency isn't it if you
win it's at someone else's expense it's
like people push a coin and then it goes
up and then there's no actual it's
almost like a Ponzi scheme it feels to
me it does yeah where it's like the more
people that invest the higher it goes in
value but at some point Ponzi schemes
tend to collapse however I you know I am
a fan of sorry to interrupt I am a fan
of I like cryptocurrency as in I like
being able to have be in control of
money without the government being
involved that's what I was about to say
that's awesome yeah I I do actually
think that cryptocurrency has certainly
got a place and I think that it is one
of the coins I'm sure will do well and
do you know what those same as nfts nfts
non-fungible tokens I think the nfts are
amazing as a service if you can use them
wow absolutely brilliant but like
investing in Logan's nft he just stupid
I think so all right so we're going to
write that what three four yeah I'll
give it three okay copyrighting I get
people picture of me every day on
Instagram Ming me saying hey I want to
be your copywriter and what are you
saying about learning the skill of being
a copywriter I think it's a very good
skill what are you going to give it out
of 10 as a moneymaking skill from 0 to
10 add of Interest before I answer that
why have you put copyrighting in what
over anything else that's a skill like
why how has that managed to make it
because I see a lot of courses on
copywriting so for instance I know that
Andrew Tate sells courses or in his real
life hus University thing he he will
have courses specifically on
copyrighting but why not video editing
for example that is another one actually
you know what let me write that down
video editing I get people all the time
asking me if they can do shorts for me
so they'll be like hey you've got
long-term content I'll turn it into
short-term content and they'll just
charge me you know and sales is another
one where people come to us I'm a great
closer all right I can't add every
single skill that's my point though why
cop CU to me because it's trending at
the moment it's popular I'm getting
loads of people dming me asking me
should I do copyrighting oh can I do
copyrighting for you and it's just
something that's popping so what are you
going to write from I would say if you I
think it's a really important skill for
any business and I think if you're
naturally a great copywriter if you
wanted to start from scratch in business
what would you write from 1 to 10 as
starting with being a copywriter and
pitching that you can copyright to it to
businesses four I've given it a seven I
think it's a really good skill and I
think that it's not only is it a really
good skill but it's a skill that a lot
of businesses suck at and I would say
video editing probably again maybe a six
but don't you think if it's poppular and
everyone's doing it and you're getting
DMS left right and Center unless you
you've got a real flare for it what do
you think about chat gbt as a copywriter
terrible horrible first he American
doesn't have a brain it's not it's not
American if you lazy creates and breeds
laziness but but don't you think that
the vast majority of the people that are
saying they want to do copyrighting are
probably going to be using stuff like
that well then they won't last will they
they they'll do one or two and it'll be
crap and you'll still you say it's
American you know that you can just say
answer this in British English and it
will do it in British English next rent
to rent uh nine why nine cuz I think
it's a fantastic way well you've done
you've done successfully are you biased
because you've done it successfully
maybe probably probably some of these
things if I was if for example if ID
made loads of money as a copywriter deal
selling property sourcing I think if I
was starting again that is what I would
do so I'm going have to give that a 10
mhm this is the thing with deal sourcing
and again I know I'm probably biased
because i' I became a millionaire from
deal sourcing but it's the same as
garage sailing and and and Drop Shipping
to a point but the difference is it kind
of but it's way better on many levels
the first level is if you're selling
crappy little teddy bears how how much
you going to make per sale a couple
pound even if you're selling trainers
how much you can to sell per sale 10 20
30 40 whereas if you're selling property
investment deals the average house is
worth about quarter of a million in the
UK If you're finding good deals and
selling them the investor is going to
happily pay you three four five grand
it's like a couple percent and another
thing Andrew Tate says which is
brilliant is he says money is like water
it's always moving and find where the
money is and get in the way and deal
sour that's where the money is there
people dropping big bucks you you're
moving into a space where there's lots
of money whereas selling teddy bears in
your garage is the exact opposite of
that right that's why I gave it a zero
but the thing is as well deal with deal
sourcing is you're also you're not even
putting any Capital down up front cuz
you're not buying trainers and then
hoping that you can resell them you're
finding properties negotiating them down
in price and then passing them to an
investor I think deal sourcing is it has
to be a 10 rent to rent again same story
like you can control small stuff oh I
got this little thing this little laptop
and but with rent to rent you're
controlling a property pushing the value
up the margins are high but also the
average rent to rent will make you what
like a grand a month it's almost passive
how much you going to make from doing
garage so you say yeah absolutely
brilliant next network marketing I'm
going to give network marketing uh
probably a nine I think it's brilliant I
did it I used to be a distributor for
utility Warehouse never made a lot of
money doing it to be fair it was a SLO
so it was a slog that you did for years
and never made a lot of money you give a
nine that makes no sense do you know why
because the amount of personal
development that I learned from it was
just so good and I met a lot of people
that weren making good money at it so
just because I didn't make I made made a
bit of money but just because I didn't
make a lot of money it' be unfair for me
to say I was not good I did make money
that started me in business I was
introduced to Jim ran from network
marketing I'm an advocate for network
marketing and I just think the idea of
building a team it's almost like running
your own business without the risk the
downside to network marketing is they
can just close the business down you
don't have complete control you're very
limited and restricted on how you can
advertise and what you can do what did
you give rent to rent a 10 and deal and
deal sell you gave a 10 10 yeah so you
think network marketing is just F be
like oh you could do rent to rent or
network marketing it's there or
thereabouts in the same ballpark is that
what you think there's very little
downside to network marketing in terms
of there's very little risk tell my one
there is more risk let me tell you my
biggest downside for um network
marketing go on my biggest downside is
I've done a few not not I'm not I've
never made very much money either which
is weird isn't it both me and you have
made loads of money in other fields I've
never made that much money in network
marketing why is that tell me we were
very young when we did network marketing
yeah we were very inexperienced right
well and then that propelled us to what
we doing now here's why I'm not a big
fan an advocate bro you're it's good I'm
glad it's good it's good that you're an
advocate right and I meet people that
that said to me have just signed oh my
husband just started network marketing
and I'm just so proud of I'm like yes
I'm one of those guys I'd like to go and
speak at the um you know like the Mad
conventions and stuff yeah I don't know
whether they'd have mebe I'm not like
through and through network marketing
but I'd love to go and encourage them
cheer them I believe in it in the same
way that I believe in education I
believe in investing in yourself I just
believe in the philosophy I learned so
much the people that you know that have
done it what percentage of them would
you say have succeeded interestingly all
of them failed however nearly all of
them they meant on to be successful in
business so you think it's a good
grounding very good grounding but not
very good for actually making money so
how could you possibly give it a nine
next no no no no I'm not I'm not letting
this go if you think it's a good
grounding but not very good for actually
making money say good for making money
but but you just said that every single
person that you know that's done it has
failed it isn't one of my issues with
network marketing I'm not even sure I'd
go stronger than that I think that they
don't care the people that set the rules
up they don't care if you're successful
or not mhm I think what they care about
the whole model with network marketing
is bug all your friends and family bug
everyone that you can think of M you've
been really harsh you've been really
really harsh what do you give it out of
10 six okay so that's better than
average that's good I'm glad we agree
next affiliate marketing I say I prefer
affiliate marketing why uh how can you
prer it when network marketing basically
is affiliate marketing with just the
fact that you can build a team because a
couple of reasons one one of the things
I I don't really like the building a
team thing because I think that did that
not help you build a team I think that
we network marketing all the focus on
building a team of low performers okay
affiliate marketing what are you going
to give it affiliate marketing I'm going
to give it a nine I think it's brilliant
I'm going to give it an eight affiliate
marketing is is what selling other
people's products and getting a
commission it's brilliant our dad makes
a lot of money as an affiliate marketer
most influencers on YouTube are
affiliate marketers they'll have links
in their bios where they'll be sending
other people's stuff if you can position
yourself as as someone of Authority or
an expert especially on social media and
then you can choose the products look
all the people that made an absolute
killing from selling Andrew tights hust
University yeah that were faceless
nameless people probably had no
personality could have been 17-year-old
kids in their basement but they were
just chopping up micro content pushing
out there putting the link made of
Fortune cool I think that's everything
then so what do you think guys do you
disagree with anything do you think the
Russell was wrong on any points do you
think I was wrong or were we both wrong
let us know in the comments how would
you rate these things from one to 10 I
hope whatever you want to do in business
I hope that you succeed even if it is
garage selling